[Music]
aj mclean's daughter got some private
dance lessons from one of the greats hi
my name is ava
and david came to do the work the
backstreet boy took to instagram on
monday showing off his nine-year-old
daughter ava's newest dance routine
courtesy of dancing with the stars
mainstay derek huff
[Music]
in the fun video you can even spot aj in
the studio mirrors capturing the moment
the singer captioned his video thank you
derek for doing a one-on-one lesson with
ava best experience ever you're a true
legend and a rock star
of course the icon couldn't leave the
studio without a collab of his own
[Music]
the last time these two shared a dance
hall was season 29 of dancing with the
stars where derek proved to be one of
aj's biggest champions aj you're such an
amazing entertainer and just an amazing
person
and again getting better and better each
and every week meanwhile aj loves
showing off his daughter's dancing
skills on instagram
and sharing father-daughter dance duets
on tiktok
[Applause]
[Music]
yup aj clearly loves being a girl dad
i have my my dance teacher right here oh
my girlfriend which is on track with the
heartfelt comments he gave vt last year
what makes it so special to be this
daddy for the girls it's literally the
most rewarding thing i've ever done in
my life to be a to be a father there's
no better job
there's no better
gift than when i come home to be
received with hugs and kisses and
cuddles from my girls
and
you know to know that
they look up to me um i thought that
would be a bunch of pressure but it's
actually
it makes me strive to be a better father
a better husband a better person
and to set a really good example and
show my girls that
i i follow my dreams and i'm able to do
what i do now for almost 30 years and if
she can you know she's doing piano
guitar dance all on her own she wants to
do this and my wife and i fully support
her and her sister
you